[Music]
[Applause]
I text Jason Jackson Jr III prior to
game seven the heat in the garden Miami
Heat play-by-play voice and I said
nervous question mark
and he was not nervous at all
it's all about the money for Jason
Jackson Jr III welcome back to the
program
all about the money I mean it's a
significant portion of the spoils your
girl shirelle wants a new kitchen okay I
mean quartz and LG's and backsplashes
and waterfalls I got but you weren't
nervous you were not you weren't nervous
about your Miami Heat why but what
because this team has done this all year
I mean like honestly when you look at
the regular season versus the postseason
the stretch of goodness hadn't really
existed in any consistent way in the
regular series I think the longest
winning streak for the heat during the
regular season was three
there are a few of them but it was the
longest winning streak so the fact that
you know they jumped out to the 3-0 lead
okay seen that
the three losses was really
two and a quarter
but they don't count them that way that
last loss was the type of thing that
gets your full attention you know but
okay you're not nervous at all going
into game seven come on pre-game for
hype video all of that you're not going
uh oh
no gangrene only has so much that they
can really toss at you that that is what
I refer to as the fan base
of the Boston Celtics gangit green okay
and when it when it got when it got
tough Danny when it got tough and I'm
talking at the beginning of the fourth
quarter no let's go back to halftime
when the booze started in game seven on
the home floor where's the jet fuel that
you're giving your your squad
that's supposed to Cascade down onto the
parquet Gang Green what
boo stop jacking it I'm like what are
they talking about uh how nervous are
you facing Denver
again
my name should be purpose you're never
nervous Purvis Allison I'm never nervous
okay uh the thing that does concern me
is that there is how do you stop Joker
like where is that uh you can run them
around I think that's the first thing
you you've got to say is let's make him
just exude as much energy as possible
defensively so now I I see bam out of
Bio starting on the Baseline for every
set and sprinting to the top of the Ark
in in 90 pick and rolls ninety and I
think that's the only way to just get a
little lather going on the other end
that you you see this and he'll get the
ball here comes the double team he is an
enormous human being he just looks over
the top of everything finds whoever's
open they'll make it or they won't but
they've been rolling so the making tends
to happen
uh you cannot shake that man and and now
that everyone is so super confident uh
it's going to be a scrambling defense
and I think that's what really helped
Miami against
I think Milwaukee was probably the
closest thing now that you get to in the
sense of and Giannis wasn't it 100 but
that's you go back and you look at that
you watch every loss in the last six
weeks and you try to figure out
something that just keeps that big
monster on the Move we're talking to
Jason Jackson play by play voice and
also TV host and uh NBA host on Sirius
XM joining us from Denver game one
coming up tonight Miami eight and a half
Point Underdog feels like both these
teams trying to embrace the nobody
thought we would be here or you know
we're The Underdogs here
Denver is a big favorite here but they
they're playing the nobody you know
wants to give us any credit uh how is
that playing do you think with the Miami
Heat
then they don't care
I mean that and it's not even disdain
for Denver having that edge that's just
the mentality of this group uh if you
saw Jimmy's uh comments yesterday that
that really leads to everything that
trickles out of the mouth of Kyle Lowry
out of uh the face of bam out of bio as
well as everybody on that roster is that
if they play if the Heat play their best
basketball then that's the best chance
to win what is that that is defending
you you know what off turning that
defense in offense and everything
becomes a little bit easier uh let us
discuss though the reality of one mile
in the air particularly the first game
that is not something to take lightly as
someone who walks three levels of stairs
in that building huffing and puffing uh
I was literally just sitting in my
broadcast location section 260. thank
you nuggets that's lovely
I'm looking down to the floor I'm
literally going I'm I'm light-headed up
here and I'm sitting still like so you
that that just getting acclimated to
that I I think most players say takes
about two quarters uh before that
happens so it's gonna be interesting to
watch how are you saying that the
altitude could affect your performance
tonight in game one
I'm going to have oxygen okay
easily accessible okay all right fair
enough yeah uh it feels like Eric
spolster and Jimmy Butler have already
won the playoffs
that that we recognize how great
spolster is nationally and Jimmy Butler
here he is again Jimmy buckets
say that fair thankfully yeah it's funny
so SPO doesn't need it and has it
disdain for even sitting and talking to
us I think I shared with you last time
Jimmy has no use for us as the the
professional observers of things
they do what is required of them in the
sense of communicating obviously after
27 years
in this business 15 is the head coach of
the Miami Heat spoke gets it and
understands that there are a couple of
layers that are there when it comes to
communicating fan base uh talk sometimes
still talking to your players that way
um that there's a usefulness
to at least allowing us to note that
you're one of the best that do this
Jimmy does not care and I don't know if
that's you know the ducats or just the
fact that he's from Tomball Texas or
this is inter wiring but it's just that
that part of it neither one of them
needs and it does radiate to some level
through the rest of the crew which makes
it an easy team to like to root for uh I
was talking to somebody one of our
colleagues from the worldwide leader and
that person was noting that if you're a
hoop head this is going to be one of
your favorites finals it may not be the
highest rated finals but as a hoop head
these two teams with some of the names
we've already talked about these are
just really good basketball players
great basketball technicians uh in the
head coaches and staffs so this is going
to be a really really good basketball
finals most likely I just don't know if
there's enough radiating from a oh yeah
casual fan that makes the finals you
know ratings Juggernaut uh Tyler hero
not playing tonight maybe not game two
maybe you're bringing back game three at
home
um could it be a bad thing if he comes
back given the injury and then trying to
come back to play in the NBA finals
it's hard to bake
20 points per game bad
but what I will say it'll be different
his usage is more I was told earlier the
season that it was at the level of
Dwyane Wade and I remember my eyes
popping out of my head because I watched
this man all the time and I'm going he
has the ball in his hands that much I
didn't realize but Tyler really worked
on his ball handling two years ago and
so he can get anywhere on the floor that
he wants and that he can score
everywhere at the basket mid-range and
three what that does sometimes as you
well know sir is someone who is a bit of
a ball hog himself absolutely is that it
does alter
the everybody else's touches
I think Tyler's been paying attention
over the last six weeks and realizing
that when the heat have five six seven
guys in double figures uh the offense is
a hell of a lot easier but that man can
score like that's literally what he does
I believe the nickname is bucket we got
a lot of buckets in our joints yeah you
can't have Jimmy bucks yeah you can't
have a couple of buckets there you got
Jimmy Butler here's Boy Wonder but I
mean the man's a father of two children
I can't call him a child anymore it's
ridiculous he's got two kids now
Tyler yeah
maybe it's the bucket hat that he's been
wearing on the sidelines is that is that
why he's known as bucket boy or whatever
nah man nah he could score him okay all
right need something else all right you
sound pretty competent here I think
you're kind of absorbing Jimmy Butler I
think you're you're taking on Jimmy
Butler's Persona here a little bit I
think it's the other way around I am the
younger now yeah I am the Elder okay all
right well have fun I am realizing that
at 51 I arrived at this job at 32 and I
was the same age as the you know the
most senior players and then you evolve
into being the same age as everybody's
crazy uncle yeah and and now I'm the
same age if not older as most of the
parents I I met you in your 20s
perspective about
I know but I'm just saying I've known
you when I saw you when you were a kid
23 yeah I arrived 23. right outside my
door my office here we go yep
Jason Jason had a cubicle right outside
my door my office you know the new guy I
served him daily
I said hello to you
right
yeah often times stole um I didn't steal
a TV from you but I told you I did it
you had two
I it wasn't Us Versus Them environment
yes it was created yes by the management
at the mothership is ridiculous yes yes
but you were a new guy I needed an extra
TV in my office and I didn't think you
were using it that much so I just
brought it into my crib
well well when you were walking out the
door and I still had four hours until my
show
yeah yeah and you were weren't you
after about a year and a half yes
all right have fun tonight and conserve
your energy okay
little small breaths like are you okay
now I mean you're in the ILO and Harlem
Nights
Marvin got that one I didn't get Danny
Island like yellow and Harley at the end
when they lock him in the safe
and Eddie Murphy tells Danny Aiello take
short breath short breaths or else
you're bleeped up okay
yeah somebody should be here to get you
out of here by Monday and this was a
Friday so he's like
you should probably take a little tiny
short breath have fun too sir okay good
luck tonight
more games more money daddy let's go
that's that's that's all he cared about
Jason Jackson Jr III the Miami Heat
radio play-by-play voice yeah I said are
you nervous he goes hey more games more
money and I go that doesn't sound like
you're nervous he goes no because I'm
not playing